The answer is that magenta matches c, yellow matches b, white matches d and
cyan matches a. But how did I figure that out? I went into BlueJ and created a
rectangle, and filled it. So I got something like this. Then when I set the
color, it changed to this sort of red-blue color. Cyan is this sort of
green-blue color. I'm pretty sure I know what yellow and white look like, so
I'll skip those ones. When I set the color to that color described by a, well,
that looks exactly like the cyan that we just saw. And if I set it to color b,
that looks like yellow to me. Color c looks like that blue red magenta color.
And color d. Well, that's just white. It doesn't show up very well on a white
background. If you're curious about this system of marking different colors,
you could try making brown or orange. But that's all we'll do with colors for
now. You've got a little more practice with graphics and a pretty cool project
coming up.